[Music]
taylor swift is nominated for yet
another moon man at the 2017 mtv video
music
award hit from the movie fifty shades
darker up for best collaboration with
zayn malik swish
and what about those rumors tay will hit
the stage with host in frenemy katy
perry i'm certainly seeing all the
rumors flying around but no that's
that's not happening
taylor is no stranger to bad blood at
the vmas
[Music]
i think people try things on the vmas
they would never try anywhere else her
2009 acceptance speech for best female
video going down in award show history
thanks to kanye west taylor
i'm really happy for you i'm let you
finish but beyonce had one of the best
videos of all time
are there any hard feelings towards him
i i don't know him and i've never met
him so the two seemed to finally bury
the hatchet after tay presented west
with the video vanguard award six years
later i guess i have to say to all the
other winners tonight
i'm really happy for you
and i'ma let you finish
but kanye west has had one of the
greatest careers of all time
there was taylor's subtle dig at ex
harry styles during her 2013 speech for
best female video
[Music]
i also want to thank the person who
inspired this song who knows exactly who
he is but as for taytay's best year at
the vmas blank space won best pop video
taylor
congratulations taylor swift blank space
as if you didn't know taylor swift
that would be 2015 when she won four out
of her 10 nominations
including video of the year for her girl
power hit
[Music]
you